mark what is the best thing about dr.
look the best thing is these brain
certian I mean you've always wanted a
brain surgeon to run for president you
almost had a heart surgery when Bill
Frist did it but he's a brain surgeon I
mean this and and frankly I mean one of
the best in the world he has a very
instinctive understanding of
particularly the I think the needs of
young children I mean he he he also I
mean is his life story is compelling and
impressive but you know his his
achievements in the field of medicine
are superlative and so the best thing
about him in general just has to be the
fact that he is one of the the best
brain surgeons perhaps there ever was
right wouldn't that be better suited to
maybe be Surgeon General perhaps than
President of the United States yeah you
know it's psychologists have this thing
they call domain specific Confederacy so
you wonder how someone who can be so
smart in one area that be so completely
dumb in another right he is not a good
politician at all he's a very very very
bad politician he's a very very very
good brain surgeon yeah and I think he's
learning that the more that the race
goes on yeah where do you think the fact
that he's african-american where does
that fall in in terms of the primary and
then the wider race let's just pretend
is you know to be honest I don't think
it matters much at all I mean I I really
so you don't think the Republican base
would care cuz that yeah I don't there's
definitely a meme about that but this
you know I don't raise I don't think so
I think I mean I think frankly the small
minority of the publican party that's
openly hardcore racist will not vote for
them other Republicans who you know
might still have subconscious or you
know beneath the surface jitters about
powerful black men understand the
political benefits of having someone
who's african-american I really just I
don't think matters yeah I know he not
give Republicans enough credit when it
comes to diversity because actually look
Herman Cain I ran Tim Scott is a
Republican senator in the south it's
easy right it's very easy to say oh but
they're all tokens and other you know
but after a while got a lot of tokens
like a lot of quarters that starts
adding up into dollars and and suddenly
you realize you know what one party is
doing a pretty good job of recruiting
minority candidates and and fast
tracking them to higher office and that
ain't the Democratic Party yeah by the
way for their good I hate the phrase
token when I cuz I used to hear it when
I I come out of the progressive world
they were always saying if there was a
black person up FoxNews
he's the token black person but what
right do I as a white person have to
tell a black birth of what they should
say III calling someone a token I think
is a you know in and of itself is I mean
it's obnoxious I agree I totally agree
and I don't I mean it there are I don't
think Republican I don't think publicans
gonna win the votes of African Americans
anytime soon for obvious reasons but at
the same time I don't think you can
ignore the enormous number of talented
politicians in the Republican Party who
are non-white alright so that said what
is the worst thing about dr. ben Carson
I mean the the worst thing about dr. ben
Carson as I said is that just his
political skills are abominable in and
can't transfer them I mean I would trust
ben Carson right now to stick his finger
in my brain and remove a clot from my
subarachnoid arteries yeah but you know
what I trust him with the nuclear codes
yeah so is that another one of those
things where on one hand sometimes we
want someone with no experience they're
fresh they don't know what they're doing
so they can try anything and then on the
other hand this is a case where maybe
one elected office might have helped a
little bit it it changes your
perspective on certain things and it's a
skill you have to master and he's not a
good politician he is a bad bad
politician